today on the matt walsh show the
sexualization of children in our culture
continues with a horrifying netflix film
about twerking 11 year olds and five
headlines including last night's dnc
convention finale and a school system
that wants parents to pledge in writing
that they will not eavesdrop on their
children's virtual classes what could go
wrong there in our daily cancellation
we're going to cancel a christian
publisher for its
exceedingly uh cringy attempt to connect
with today's youth all of that on the
way but starting here september 9th
streaming behemoth netflix will debut a
new film on its platform titled cuties
uh the movie
by french writer and director i'm not
even gonna try to pronounce the name but
uh french writer and director follows
the exploits of eleven-year-old amy
who hopes to break free from her
conservative senegalese upbringing by
joining a twerking
dance troupe the official synopsis tells
us that amy through her quote sensual
dancing will quote ignite
awareness of her burgeoning femininity
but will the girls successfully quote
twerk
their way to stardom you'll have to
watch to find out that is if you're on a
registry somewhere and interested
in watching that kind of content now
probably
though probably not on registries many
film critics are indeed apparently
interested in that kind of content
the film currently has a depressing
around 80 percent
fresh rating on rotten tomatoes critics
tell us that the um
the story of pubescent children dancing
sensually is
a quote compelling crowd pleaser that
quote
heralds an indelible directorial voice
and must be quote
respected for its audacity now
much of the backlash and discussion
about this movie has been centered
around the horrific
promotional image that netflix put
together um
and was until a couple days ago using on
their site now here it is right here you
can see it
as you can see 11 year old girls
scantily clad striking their quote
unquote sensual poses
one of them on all fours as people
became aware of the movie and a petition
was formed to get it tossed from the
platform and
outrage grew netflix decided to change
the synopsis of the film
and get rid of this image and they
issued also an apology
here's their apology uh you tell me if
it really gets to the heart of the
matter or not says we're deeply sorry
for the inappropriate artwork that we
used
for cuties it was not okay nor was it
representative of this french film which
premiered at sundance
we've now updated the pictures and
description okay by the way the fact
that it's a french film that premiered
at sundance in no way indicates that
it's not
horrible and exploitative sundance was
co-founded by a man who's now imprisoned
for raping children after all
but you notice how netflix offers no
apology for the content of the film
itself
nor do they promise to get rid of it
instead they just put up a different
poster defenders of the movie and yes
it has defen defenders it does say that
well you can't judge a book by its cover
it's not fair to condemn a movie you
haven't seen
what they don't understand is that
normal well-adjusted non-creepy adults
have no interest in watching a movie
that features 11 year olds twerking in
any capacity or context
even if it was just one scene much much
less a central plot point
in fact you can judge a book by its
cover sometimes and this is one of those
times
other defenders including some of those
film critics mentioned before claim that
the film is a
commentary on the sexualization of
children
now even if you're inclined to buy that
rather in my opinion dubious excuse
doesn't change how netflix chose to
promote the film through its marketing
material
i don't care if this is a movie about
kids at a lemonade stand or something it
if the company distributing it is trying
to sell it
as quote unquote sensual that's a huge
problem in and of itself
but is the commentary excuse credible
well take note of the fact that
according to an interview
and variety with the cuties producer
they filled the lead role
with an 11 year old actress if they're
looking to give critical commentary on
the sexualization of children
it's hard to understand why they would
want 11 year olds to provide the gem the
demonstration
it seems rather counterproductive to
decry something by actually
doing the thing you are decrying uh
there was an
interview in the wrap with the director
of the film and
she explained her reasons for making the
film i'm going to read now from the rap
it says
the director explained how growing up in
france with traditional parents from
senegal
made her want to explore in cuties the
question of whether we should quote have
the right
to choose which women we can be in this
world in our culture even today i can
say i'm not totally free
because i love to wear short dresses and
at the same time when i go to a
religious ceremony
i wear a veil just choose as a woman
what do you want to be
okay that was her reason that she gave
the point as explained by the director
seems quite different
from calling attention to child sexual
exploitation
this would seem to be much more a
display of that sexualization than a
commentary on it
so perhaps cuties will comment on the
sexualization of children in the same
way that a film like the purge
comments on violence namely by going out
of its way to appeal to the sorts of
people
who want to see the thing that the film
is allegedly criticizing
that's not commentary at all it's
exhibition
and here's the main thing we have to
understand this is not an isolated
incident
this movie is not happening in a vacuum
or out of the blue
this is part of a long-running trend in
our culture towards the sexualization of
children
and the normalization of pedophilia it
is a
it is a trend um even just in the
universe of netflix it's a trend for
years now the streaming platform has
aired a cartoon aimed at teens
called big mouth that advocates
masturbation pornography
and things even more graphic than that
so they've been down this road before
plenty of times also this isn't this
isn't netflix but another example bears
mentioning
uh just a few weeks ago a film called
yes god yes
another masterpiece according to critics
anyway was released to streaming
and on demand viewing um and according
to the stylist
it uh quote unquote to hear here's the
quote explores the joys and shame of
female masturbation
through the adventures of its 16 year
old protagonist
uh the writer and director karen mayne
says that she's hoping the film helps
her younger audience
feel less weird about discovering their
sexuality
but but really the most egregious form
of child exploitation and sexualization
in our culture
has nothing to do with films about
twerking
in fact in this vein uh netflix aired
something even more objectionable
not long ago the reboot of the
babysitter's club
recently featured a um a storyline about
a nine-year-old
trans girl i.e a boy who has been told
by his parents that he's a girl
and let's just look at here's just one
short scene from that episode look at
this
okay took a while but we finally found a
file for a bailey del vecchio
is 32 burnt hill road still the current
address yeah have you been giving him
fluids if he's dehydrated we'll need to
place an iv
have him change into this i don't want
the blue one
um well i hear someone's not feeling
well
let's take a look at the little man
can i please talk to you two outside
i know that you guys are busy but
as you would see if you looked at her
and not her chart
bailey is not a boy and by treating her
like one you are completely ignoring who
she is
you're making her feel insignificant and
humiliated
and that's not gonna help her feel good
or safe or calm
so i'm here on now please recognize her
for who she is
and if at all possible could you find me
a non-blue hospital gown or bonus
[Music]
now of course leaving all the other
issues aside here there are many
excellent reasons why doctors
might need to know your actual
biological sex it can affect what
treatment they use
because as it turns out boys and girls
are different very different
but more to the point here this is a
storyline normalizing the idea that
young children can choose their own
gender
and you should know that the actor who
goes by the name kai
is a biological boy who identifies as a
girl according to his mother he started
showing signs of being a girl at 18
months
yes 18 months this mother believes that
an 18 month old
baby has some sort of insight into his
own gender
which of course is stark raving lunacy
kai completed his transition at four
four now i have an almost four-year-old
plus two other kids who were four at one
point one time
and i can report unequivocally that
four-year-olds have
no idea what gender is have
no idea what boys and girls are really
if you don't believe me just ask a
four-year-old what's a boy what's a girl
they won't be able to tell you
they have indeed no idea what anything
is they have no grasp on reality
whatsoever there's a reason you can tell
these kids that a giant fat man flies
through the air at the speed of light
climbs down their chimneys and brings
them presents and they won't even
question the claim or bat and i they
accept it implicitly
like they accept everything else because
they they don't have the psychological
capacity to distinguish between fact and
fiction
reality and fantasy by accepting and
promoting and
imposing this absurd grotesque
mind-boggling lie that four-year-olds
can choose their own gender
that they have somehow the maturity and
agency and insight and understanding and
competency to make life-altering
decisions for themselves
at that age we are sending the message
that well
four-year-olds have maturity agency
understanding and competency
we are sending the message that
four-year-olds have enough psychological
neurological and emotional development
to choose their sex
which is to say according to this theory
they have quite a significant amount
of psychological neurological and
emotional development
the problem here well one of the
countless problems
is that the whole reason
what is the whole reason we say that
adulthood starts at 18
and that for example a sexual
relationship between an adult and a
minor is not
a relationship at all but abuse the
reason we give is that children
are not psychologically neurologically
and emotionally developed
the entire basis for the laws that allow
us
to put adults who prey on children in
jail is that children
quite literally can not consent to
sexual relationships
because they don't understand what
they're doing or what the consequences
are
or what it means etc etc etc
and yet now we're saying oh never mind
in fact children even at the age of four
actually are
enormously mature and developed so much
so that they can choose to alter their
entire identity
and make decisions that will have a
profound impact on their lives forever
even to the point of taking drugs that
will chemically castrate them
so you see where this leads hopefully
what we have here is a developing
narrative about childhood
and childhood psychology and the
capacities of children
that is extraordinarily dangerous and
can only lead to terrible things
and that is we should emphasize
completely wrong
on every level and contrary to science
common sense morality and basic human
decency so yes
the movie about the twerking girls is
bad but it's a lot worse than that out
there for our children
which is all the more reason if you're a
parent to keep your kids close
and remain vigilant let's go to five
headlines
[Music]
i want to tell you about another one of
our loyal sponsors and a big thank you
to all of our sponsors who have uh
helped us get through
you know these difficult times over the
last few months and we would ask you to
you know uh just support our sponsors if
you hear a product or service that
sounds like you need and might be
interested in
then um we we thank you for
for supporting them and supporting us
and uh
especially here with with this sponsor
bambi listen um
hr issues can really kill you if you're
if you're running a a company and you
know this if you're
a small business owner business owner of
any size
hr issues uh can be one of the most
difficult things to deal with wrongful
termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations all the red tape these days
it just gets it gets even more
complicated every single day it seems
like
and hr manager salaries aren't cheap an
average of 75 000
a year bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was
created specifically for small
businesses
you can get a dedicated hr manager you
can craft hr policy maintain your
compliance all for just 99
a month okay with bambi you can change
hr from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
managers available by phone email
or real-time chat so you've got that
you've got someone who's always there
for you from onboarding to terminations
they customize your policies to fit your
business
and they help manage your employees
day-to-day all for just
99 a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time
and uh you don't start your business
because you know you wanted to spend
time on hr compliance i don't think
that's anyone's dream when they start a
business
is that they really want to get into hr
and worry about all the red tape
compliance
so let bambi take care of that get your
free hr audit today
go to bambi.com walsh right now to
schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com walsh b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh
all right let's go to um see what
headlines we got here number one the dnc
convention last night
we did our all-access watch party for
that hopefully you were able to join it
was the worst thing that's ever happened
to me
personally um i maintain though and i
survived for three hours
in one of the great feats of human
endurance of all time
the big headline from the convention i
suppose is that there was no real
headline they successfully avoided
headlines which i think is part of the
point here
certainly that's that is the the
strategy of the joe biden campaign is to
not make it into the headlines and i i
think they basically did that last night
anyway the entire focus of the
convention
really was uh or at least last night
seemed to be
that joe biden is a really nice guy
right
and that's why they told us he's a nice
guy again and again
and again and again and again by my
account there were approximately 75
slow motion video montages or at least
felt like 75
slow motion video montages piano music
uh you know and it just telling us that
joe's a nice guy at one point his
grandchildren showed
up to talk about his favorite flavor of
ice cream and what toppings he likes
i'm not kidding that's how vacuous this
thing was and then joe biden got up
there
at the end and when i was half dead at
that point delivered a speech um all i
could say is that the dnc is thanking
god
or or gaia or whoever the divine spirit
actually they had their
their uh their nun their fake nun give
a an invocation and she she prayed to
the divine spirit
but anyway uh whoever they're thanking
someone that the speech didn't have to
be live so i don't know how many takes
it took to nail the speech but the final
product was not bad
much to my chagrin you know no flubs no
gaffs
just a just a fine speech i don't think
anyone's going to remember it
i don't think anyone remembers it now
but uh
it was it was okay there was there were
a few moments of cringe though
uh and i i think probably the most
extreme cringe
came from this so what did you think
about kamala harris's speech last night
it was tremendous i was so happy for her
i know me too she's fabulous i cannot
wait to see her debate our current vice
president mika pines
or uh is it paints
it's pronounced ponce i believe oh
some kind of weird foreign name yeah not
very american sounding
yeah that's what people are saying
strongly
well uh thank you andrew and please give
my regards to the gang
i will they're right in the next room
have a great night julia
thank you so much yeah all the comedy
bits were about as effective as that
the comedy was so lame and bad that i
almost thought i was at a republic that
i was watching a republican convention a
few times that's how bad it was
but then i remembered that i wasn't
because every speaker would carve out
some time in their remarks actually
about 75 percent of their remarks
would be allotted to informing us that
orange man
is indeed bad if you didn't know uh so
they did tell us that so that's what we
got joe biden is nice
orange man is bad that was that was the
message
let's go on here number two uh reading
now from the daily wire says the chicago
police department has banned protesters
from demonstrating on the block where
mayor lori lightfoot lives
ordering officers to arrest anyone who
won't leave
the directive surfaced in a july email
from then shakespeare district commander
melvin roman to off
officers under his command it did not
distinguish between the peaceful
protester lightfoot regularly says she
supports and those who might intend to
be destructive
chicago police have been blocking access
to the area using barricades and police
and riot gear
and lightfoot
told reporters on thursday that she and
her family have been receiving threats
daily she says i think that residents of
the city understand
the nature of the threats that we are
receiving on a daily basis on a daily
basis understand
i have a right i have a right to make
sure that my home is secure
right this is the same woman you may
remember who banned residents from
getting haircuts under threat of
imprisonment
and then went on and got her own haircut
so this is all par for the course
uh and in the reason for getting the
haircut the reason she gave
was that she needed to look good
which well no comment on that but the
point is
that this is one of the biggest
hypocrites in the country and the
hypocrisy here
really isn't even funny or ironic or
anything it's just pure evil
in fact she lets rioters destroy
neighborhoods
terrorize residents uh do what they want
but oh no not her house not her house
can't come there
and how does she justify the double
standard you know in her own mind how do
you think she justifies it
well i'll tell you exactly how she's
more important than you simple as that
and that is what she believes and that's
how she governs
let's go number three uh back to the
daily wire it says a school district in
tennessee is asking parents
to sign a form agreeing not to monitor
their children's virtual classrooms over
concerns that
that non-student observers could
overhear
confidential information the form a copy
of which was sent to the tennessee star
reads
quote rcs strives to present these
opportunities in a secure format
that pr that protects student privacy to
the greatest extent possible however
because these meetings will occur
virtually rcs is limited in its ability
to fully control certain factors
such as non-student observers that may
be present in a home
of a student participating in the
virtual meeting the agreement goes on to
strongly discourage
non-student observation of online
meetings due to the potential of
confidential information about a student
being revealed
the agreement of course raised parents
interest according to the tennessee star
particularly given that the agreement
implied
items of interest might be being
discussed in classrooms without parents
knowledge
in an email to parents sent earlier this
week the rutherford school district said
that they
they're taking parents concerns under
advisement
uh they said we are aware of the concern
that has been raised about the distance
learning ladder that was sent out
the intent was not to prevent parents
from being involved with their children
during
distance learning but it was intended to
protect the academic privacy of other
students in the classroom
who are visible during certain virtual
class sessions yeah
um listen you know
you get a letter like that from your
school and
i i don't know how you react in any
other way than just pulling your kid out
plain and simple
they're confidential information
no no there shouldn't be any
confidential information being shared in
a classroom
there shouldn't be any information that
you as a teacher
know about your students that the
parents don't know
but like we talked about last last week
and we've talked about before
you know they're just telling on
themselves here and what their real
agenda is so you just got to get your
kids out of the school i think it really
is that simple
number four the washington post reports
the kansas city chiefs said thursday
that they will prohibit fans from
wearing headdresses and native american
themed face paint
to home games at arrowhead stadium the
team announced the measures as part of
what it calls ongoing dialogue with a
group of local leaders from diverse
american indian backgrounds and
experiences
and recent consultation with a national
organization that works closely on
issues affecting american indian people
and tribes
so even though they're the kansas city
chiefs
and that's their mascot you're not
allowed to dress that way for the for
the home game
nobody can explain why this is offensive
it's just like assumed now
that if you were to dress up as native
american it's automatically
why what's offensive about it
uh if if anything it's it's honoring a
culture
and of course as many people point out
it's almost nobody
worries about this on st patrick's day
people are dressed up like leprechauns
drinking green beer getting drunk like
that's what you do
that's how you celebrate irish culture
to dress up like a leprechaun and get
drunk
nobody complains uh and as a person of
irish ancestry i don't complain either
it just doesn't bother me but this
somehow is offensive
for reasons that are not explained okay
five finally uh big news here it's being
reported
that the band bts has probably broken a
record by getting
10 million views on their latest music
video in 20 minutes
10 million in 20 minutes
10 million people that's that's an
incredible number for just 20 minutes
now i have um
never heard of the band bts is my first
time ever i don't know what they are
i think they're a boy band uh but you
know i think back in my back but
go back to the old days you know way
back in ancient times
music videos were were aired on
and kids don't know this they were aired
on something called television
uh there were these things called
channels that you would go to
and if you wanted to see a video you had
to just sit and watch the channel
all day and hope that they played it and
there would be these things called
commercials
in between and it is very similar to the
experience you have
there's also this thing called a radio
you would listen to and uh if you wanted
to like make a mix table you couldn't
download it on the internet because it
didn't exist so
what you do is you take a blank
something called a cassette tape
and you put it in this thing called a
boom box and then you just listen to the
radio
all day and those of us were avid
mixtape makers like i was
um it was you know this this would be a
this would be hours-long project if you
want to make a mixtape and get like
10 songs on a tape but you wait for the
song to play
you got your fingers on record as soon
as it plays boom you hit record
sometimes you get a little bit of the
commercial beforehand
in the in the recording but that's fine
too that's how it worked back then but
now
and so if you if one music video was
going to get
10 million views cumulatively it would
take probably about 19 months for that
to happen
and now it happens in a little over 19
minutes
so pretty incredible but congrats to the
uh
to the guys over there at bts big fan
big fan of theirs
i just decided that right now because
that's i'm in touch
with uh with the youth of today of
course speaking of which let's get to
our daily cancellation
now for our daily cancellation this will
be a short one because i'm not intending
to pile on but i also can't possibly let
this week
come to an end without mentioning it and
besides i have no control over the daily
cancellations the cancellations come to
me
as though in a dream and i can only
accept them so today we will be
canceling lifeway
which some of you probably know is a
major christian publisher distributor
they teamed up with a group called
sunday cool to put out a devotional for
the youngins the youth gen z
and it's called the word according to
gen z um
you hear that and if you've been around
the block enough you're probably
thinking
oh no this is going to be bad and yes
you're right your insight is correct it
is it it
certainly is now lifeway has already
pulled down the devotional
um they aren't selling it anymore after
the rather negative reaction to it and
they've apologized
they say that what i'm about to read to
you was meant to be playful
but they were they regret it now and uh
you know that it was taken the wrong way
and so they pulled it down and in
fairness
i'll tell you that this devotional does
or did i guess before it was removed
from sale
seem to have plenty of perfectly fine
sort of normal devotional stuff
meditations reflections prompts that
kind of thing
and um all of that from what i saw uh
though i didn't read the whole thing
seems to be unobjectionable and
and you know even even some of it's
pretty good the issue though are the gen
z bible translations that are at the top
of each new chapter
each new day in the devotional and this
is the part that lifeway says was meant
to be playful but let me read a few of
these
to you and just to give you an idea and
you tell me what you think
okay hebrews 4 12 originally says for
the word of god is alive and active
sharper than any double-edged sword it
penetrates even to
dividing soul and spirit joints and
marrow it judges the thoughts and
attitudes of the heart
the gen z translation uh this is this is
the way it's translated it says
cap g's words are one hundo straight up
slicing and dicing and knowing it all
capgea is god in case you were confused
straight up slicing and dicing is
supposed to be i guess something that
kids say and admittedly
my kids are still young but i've never
heard a teenager ever use the phrase
straight up slicing and dyson that
sounds like maybe something that teenage
mutant ninja turtles
might have said in 1996 i don't know um
moving on okay this one really got a
rather negative reaction online
john 1 1 of course one of the most
famous and sacred lines in
in the holy scripture says in the
beginning was the word and the word was
with god and the word was god
here's the gen z translation since de
uno there was cap g
big j was chilling with cap g and big j
was cap g
you know call me crazy but i think kids
are capable of understanding a phrase
like in the beginning
in fact i i think since day uno would
sound as weird to them
and as confusing to them as it does to
us olds i don't know
psalm 119 11 originally and by
originally i mean in english of course
if i was reading the actual original
translation
um of any of these verses i'd be reading
in hebrew or greek but
anyway it says i have hidden your heart
in my i have hidden your word in my
heart that i might not sin against you
gentified it becomes i got your holy
scripts
padlocked in my chest thumper yes
chest thumper which sounds like what
perhaps a man raised in a cave by bears
might call a heart
i'm pretty sure that kids just call it a
heart though you know
ephesians 6 17 is take the helmet of
salvation and the sword of the spirit
which is the word of god and now for gen
z it's
take that noggin guard of savies and
that big old knife of cap g
cap g's words yes noggin guard
because you know kids with their slang
like noggin
noggin guard sounds at best like what
maybe the fonz might have called a
helmet in an episode of happy days
maybe one more just for good measure
psalm 34
4 says i sought the lord and he answered
me he delivered me from all my fears
but to connect with the youth of today
it is now i marco polowed
cap g and he didn't leave me on reed and
snatched up all my scaries
i have no idea what any of that means
okay so you get the idea
and as i said lifeway has already
retreated from this they said it was
supposed to be playful
and a parody even now you can decide if
it makes sense to include
parody versions of bible verses in your
devotional
uh and and again i i feel no need to
pile on but an important lesson can be
found here because
even if you want to claim parody or
playful or whatever
uh even so this would seem to perfectly
encapsulate
everything christians do wrong with
trying to connect with the youth
a real learning opportunity here one of
the biggest mistakes and most common
mistakes is talking down
to them to younger people when you
assume that kids can't understand the
most
basic words and concepts or that they
need it repeated to them in language
more appropriate for cavemen
all you're doing is insulting the people
you're trying to reach you're also
making a false assumption
you know kids though they as we
discussed at the top of the show are not
fully developed psychologically
emotionally or spiritually
they still have an enormous capacity to
learn and grow that's all they do
actually absorb things they're like
sponges
and any parent knows this so what do you
want them to absorb
is the question but now stupidity
or beauty and depth and meaning
we often deprive our children of beauty
and depth and meaning
substituting it for banal stupidity on
the assumption
that they can't handle anything deeper
than that or they'll be bored by it and
all that does is train them to reject
the very thing we want them to embrace
feed stupidity to kids and they become
stupid
simple equation there another mistake is
is trying to mimic
what kids can already get out in the
world you know see the thing is if kids
want irreverence
and slang and vulgarity and so on
they can get that anywhere and they'll
get a much more authentic
version of it anywhere else when you try
to give it to them in a church or
religious setting
it comes off as inauthentic inauthentic
and by the way kids have a
very finely tuned radar for authenticity
even my seven-year-olds have an
impressively sophisticated ability
to know when someone is being
inauthentic with them which is why kids
laugh and roll their eyes with the
you know when the youth counselor turns
the hat around backwards starts using
slang and so on
yet the church keeps employing these
tactics no matter how often they fail
so look it's the same thing i have to
remember with my own kids
if i want my kids to be a certain way
to have a certain characteristic i have
to demonstrate it
i can't expect to see from them what i
have not demonstrated
for example when i look at my kids and
i'm disappointed at their lack of
patience
that's when i have to you know have this
really painful moment of self-reflection
where i go oh right
i'm not patient enough they don't show
patience because they haven't been
provided with an adequate and consistent
demonstration
it's the same thing here you want kids
to be reverent
to appreciate beauty to understand
difficult
concepts they need it demonstrated
like it says in proverbs train up a
child in the way he should go
and when he's old he will not depart
from it and i don't think we need a gen
z version of that for the kids
either and we'll leave it there
for the week hope you guys have a great
weekend enjoy yourselves
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there
you